hi everyone
this is professor indus science and
today i want to discuss
hermit polynomials in another one of our
videos on rigorous quantum mechanics
polynomials are
a rather basic family of mathematical
functions so you may wonder why we give
a name
to a specific subset of polynomials it's
basically a shorthand we give a specific
name to a group of mathematical objects
when we use them regularly hermit
polynomials are used in a variety of
areas including statistics
combinatorics or signal processing for
us they are important because we can
write down
the energy eigenfunctions of the quantum
harmonic oscillator
in terms of hermit polynomials so
today's video is one of our
more mathematical videos and we're going
to do two main things
first we will introduce hermit
polynomials and we will discuss some
concepts such as
generating functions and second we will
see how we can write down the energy
eigenfunctions of the quantum harmonic
oscillator
in terms of hermit polynomials so let's
go
hermit polynomials are typically labeled
with the symbol hn
of z and the n here denotes the order of
the polynomial
before we say anything else we need to
clarify that there are two slightly
different definitions of the hermit
polynomials
one called the probabilists hermit
polynomials
and the other is the physicists hermit
polynomials
as you may suspect we're going to use
the physicists convention
but whenever you consult the literature
make sure that you are aware of which
convention they're using because it
might be different to the one that we've
decided to use
even within the physicists convention
there are many definitions of the hermit
polynomials
and the one that we'll start with is
that hn of z
is equal to -1 to the power of n the
exponential of
z-squared times the nth order derivative
of the exponential of minus z squared
now this is just the definition so in
principle that's all there is to it
we can construct the hermit polynomial
of order n by calculating the nth
derivative
of a gaussian here and then multiplying
by this prefactor
the first question you may have is that
we've claimed that the hn
here are polynomials of order n but the
definition essentially involves two
exponentials so it isn't immediately
obvious
that this combination of exponentials
gives you a polynomial
to convince ourselves that this is the
case we can start by looking at a few
examples
so let's start with n equals zero using
the definition
h0 is given by this
which is equal to one so it is indeed a
zeroth order polynomial
let's move to n equals one h1
it is given by the pre-factor and then
the first derivative of the gaussian and
the expression simplifies to do z
which is indeed a first order polynomial
hooray
for n equals 2 we have h2 we again start
with the pre-factor
then we need the second derivative of
the gaussian but we already calculated
the first derivative here
so all we need is the derivative of this
quantity which has these two terms
simplifying we get 4z squared minus 2
which is
again a second-order polynomial
this shows that the definition up here
does indeed give a polynomial of order n
for the first few values of n and you
can sort of
see that it would work for any n however
we want to prove it properly for the
general case
and that's what we will do next
for the general result we'll use what's
called a proof by induction
essentially we'll show that if we assume
that h
n minus 1 is a polynomial of order n
minus 1
then this implies that h n is a
polynomial for
n as we've already seen that this is
true for the first few
n then combining these two results
completes the proof that h
n are polynomials of order in
starting with the definition up here we
rewrite it for the case
n minus one
in the proof by induction we now assume
that in this case
hn minus one here is a polynomial of
degree n minus one
and all we have to prove is that this
implies that h
n is then a polynomial of degree n
to do so we first reorganize this
expression by isolating the
n minus one order derivative of the
gaussian
and set it equal to this
we next evaluate the nth order
derivative of the gaussian
which we can simply calculate as the
derivative with respect to z
of this expression here for the n minus
one order derivative
we first have the factor of minus 1 to
the power of
n minus 1 then using the chain rule
we obtain the term with the derivative
of h
plus the term with the derivative of the
gaussian
the gaussian terms here and here are a
common factor
so we can rewrite this expression like
this
note that i have also taken an extra
factor of -1 and
included it here
we can now rearrange to write the term
in square brackets
as equal to this prefactor times the nth
derivative of the gaussian
if we look at the definition of hn up
here we see that this final expression
is simply the hermit polynomial of order
n
we have arrived at a recurrence relation
the hermit polynomial of order n
is equal to this expression in terms of
the hermit polynomial of
order n minus 1. hn
minus 1 here is by hypothesis a
polynomial of degree n minus 1.
this set here then makes hn a polynomial
of degree
n and this completes the proof by
induction
up here confirming that our definition
of hermit polynomials in terms of
derivatives of a gaussian function
does indeed give polynomials of order in
polynomials such as the hermit
polynomials can often be defined in many
different ways
of which this is just an example other
definitions
involve contour integrals differential
equations
or generating functions from a practical
point of view as physicists
these alternative ways of looking at
polynomials simply provide
different ways in which we can approach
a problem and
the most appropriate form will depend on
the problem at hand
as we're going to see later a
particularly useful form
for the purpose of describing the
eigenstates of the quantum harmonic
oscillator
will be using generating functions but
more on that in a few minutes
first let's look at the plots of the
first few hermit polynomials
this first one is h0 which is simply
equal to one so a constant
the second one is h1 which is two z a
straight line
this one is h2 which is a quadratic
function
for z squared minus two moving on to the
second row
note that here each diagram now has a
different vertical axis
this one is h3 which is a cubic function
this is h4 which is a quartic function
and the final one is h5 which is a
polynomial of order
five let's now turn to
parity we want to show that all hermit
polynomials have a definite parity
which means that they are either even or
odd functions
and we'll again use induction we'll
start with the assumption
we're going to assume that the hermit
polynomial of order n
minus 1 has a definite parity which
could be either even or odd
and we don't have to specify which one
the first part of the proof is to show
that if h
n minus 1 has definite parity then
h n has the opposite parity
to do so we're going to use the
recurrence relation between
h n and h n minus 1
that we derived in the second slide
we now consider hn of minus it
plugging in this relation in here we get
this
and i now take the factor of -1 from the
bracket
to get this
as hn minus 1 is by assumption or fixed
parity
then it means that this is even or
odd let's first consider the case of
even h n minus one
this means that this term here is h n
minus one of z and this whole term here
is then simply h n of z
taking this factor of minus one into
account we can conclude
that h n is an odd function
let's now make some room now we can
consider that second possibility which
is that
h n minus 1 is odd
in this case this term here is minus h n
minus 1 of z
so this whole time here is minus h n of
z
taking this factor of minus 1 into
account we can conclude
that h n is an even function
overall we've just proved that if h n
minus 1 is an even function then h n is
an
odd function and that if h n minus 1 is
an
odd function then h n is an even
function
put another way if a hermit polynomial
of order n
minus 1 has definite parity then the
hermit polynomial order n
has the opposite parity
let's see if this conclusion works for
the first few hermit polynomials that we
derived just a minute ago
we found that h0 of z is equal to one
h1 of z is equal to 2z and h2 of z
is equal to 4z squared minus 2. from
this we see clearly that
h0 is an even function h1 is an odd
function
and h2 is an even function
this means that the first few hermit
polynomials have a definite parity
completing the proof by induction we can
conclude that
all hermit polynomials have definite
parity
but there is more that we can extract
from our proof
consecutive hermit polynomials have
opposite parity
the zeroth and second order polynomials
have even parity
and the first order polynomial has odd
parity
so going back to the top we can conclude
that h n of
minus z is equal to minus 1 to the power
of
n times h n of z
and this means that permit polynomials
of order
n are even for even n
and odd for odd n
if you need further convincing we can go
back to our graphs of the first few
hermit polynomials
and we indeed see that h0 h2 and h4
are even functions and h1 h3 and
h5 are odd functions
so as promised earlier we're now going
to look at the hermit polynomials in
terms of a generating
function generating functions are a very
powerful tool in mathematics that allow
us to encode an
infinite sequence such as the whole
family of hermit polynomials
by treating them as the coefficients of
a power series
let's see how this comes about consider
this two variable function g of z and t
given by the exponential of minus t
squared plus two t z
note that minus z minus t squared can be
expanded
to this
and reorganizing we get this
this means that we can rewrite g as a
product of this exponential
and this other exponential as i
anticipated a moment ago
the power of generating functions
becomes apparent
when we consider power series so
we write g again and now expanded about
t
equals 0 in the variable t getting this
let's focus on the nth order derivative
of g evaluated at t equals 0.
plugging in this expression for g up
here we get this
the partial derivative with respect to t
of a general function
f of z minus t is equal to minus the
partial derivative with respect to z
so we can use this result here to end up
with this
as this quantity is evaluated at t
equals 0
and now the derivative is no longer with
respect to t
then we can directly set this t in the
exponent to zero
we can now go all the way back to the
original power expansion
and using these results for the
derivative we can rewrite it like this
we now recognize this term as the hermit
polynomial of order
n and we can finally write that g
z t is equal to this power series so
what does this mean
the hermit polynomials are the
coefficients of the series expansion of
the function g
and for this reason this is called the
generating function of the hermit
polynomials
in other words we can directly read of
the value of
say the zeroth order hermit polynomial
by looking at the first term in the
series
the first order hermit polynomial we can
get as the second term in the series
and so on it's a convenient and really
compact way of encoding the information
and as we'll see extremely useful for
proofs as well
in particular generating functions will
prove very useful in relating the hermit
polynomials
to the eigenstates of the quantum
harmonic oscillator
up to this point we've looked at the
properties of the hermit polynomials and
our discussion has been purely
mathematical
so what i want to do in the rest of this
video is to show how we can relate the
hermit polynomials to the eigenfunctions
of the quantum harmonic oscillator
in particular we'll show that the
eigenfunctions of the quantum harmonic
oscillator
are given by this prefactor
a gaussian and a hermit polynomial
as you've probably guessed we're going
to use generating functions to prove
this
we've just seen that we can write the
generating function g
as equal to this expansion where the
expansion coefficients are hermit
polynomials
in parallel we will conveniently design
another function
h of two variables x and lambda
equal to this power series in lambda
where the coefficients are the
eigenfunctions of the quantum harmonic
oscillator
you will notice that the form of the two
functions is strikingly similar
in the next few slides we'll show that
we can write an equation
relating g and h as both are given by
power series
then equating the different powers will
allow us to derive this expression up
here
for the eigenfunctions of the quantum
harmonic oscillator
so this is the strategy that will follow
let's get started
we start with the function h that we
just defined
where i have now used the bracket xn to
write
the eigenfunction and we want to
manipulate this expansion
until we end up with an expression
resembling g
the generating function of the hermit
polynomials
i will assume that you are familiar with
the properties of the quantum harmonic
oscillator
but if you're not then you can find all
the relevant videos
linked in the description we know from
the video on eigenfunctions that we can
write the state
n as this prefactor and then apply the
raising operator
n times on the ground state plugging
this into the state
n here we can rewrite h as equal to this
we can then move these scalars into the
bracket here and we end up with this
this here is a taylor expansion of an
exponential function
this is our first step we can write h
of x lambda as the bracket x e
to the power lambda a dagger acting on
the ground state
this is the latest expression that we
got for the function h
we're now going to focus on this
exponential here
let's first copy it and we now use the
definition
of the raising operator in terms of the
position and momentum operators to get
this remember that we first encountered
this definition in the video on the
ladder operators so check it out if you
need a refresher
the argument of the exponential is the
sum of two operators x and p
so to make progress we need to figure
out how to simplify that type of
expression
if they were scalars we would know how
to factorize it
the exponential of a times the
exponential of b
is equal to the exponential of a plus b
but this relation doesn't hold for
operators in general
instead we can write this
and the operator c is given by this
series
this is called the baker campbell house
door formula
which we are not going to prove we can
see that if the a and b operators
commute
then this expression reduces to the
expression we have for scalars
but if a and b don't commute then we
have
additional terms in our case the
operators are position and momentum
which obey the canonical commutation
relation
so they don't commute this means
that this third term will be non-zero
however the commutator of x and p is a
scalar
so all other terms in this series will
vanish
going back to our original exponential
of lambda a dagger
we can now write it down as an
exponential of the position operator
times an exponential of the momentum
operator
times an exponential of their commutator
using the value of the commutator we see
that this last term is simply a scalar
we're now ready to go back to the h
function plugging in this expression for
the exponential
we can write h as equal to this scalar
exponential
times this bracket of the exponential of
the position operator
and the exponential momentum operator
all acting on the ground state
as the position operator is her mission
it can act on this bra
which is a position eigen state so these
terms
simply give the broad times a scalar
exponential
just to emphasize it this x here is now
a scalar the eigenvalue of the position
eigenstate
overall this means that we can rewrite h
as
these two scalar exponentials
times this bracket that now only
involves
the exponential of the momentum operator
and there is now something in this
expression that might look familiar to
some of you
if you've seen our video on translation
operators you will remember that a
translation by alpha is encoded by the
operator
t alpha which is equal to the
exponential
of minus i alpha p over h bar
and if you don't we've linked the video
in the description so you can take a
quick look
this operator acts on a position eigen
state by translating it by an
amount alpha the equivalent equation in
geospace becomes
this you can now see
that this exponential up here has the
form of a translation operator
where the translation is given by the
square root of
h bar over 2m omega lambda
this means that the bra x times this
exponential
is equal to the bra x displaced by the
negative of the translation
we can now go back to h and it is equal
to the two scalar exponentials
times this bracket
now this bracket here is simply the
ground state wave function of the
quantum harmonic oscillator at
x minus the translation from the video
on eigenfunctions we know that the
ground state wave function of the
harmonic oscillator is given by this
expression
so we can write h in the following way
first we consider this pre-factor to get
this
then these two scalar exponentials up
here to get this
and finally the gaussian here but
remembering that the argument is
displaced
we get this
we're now going to combine the three
exponentials into a single one
which we can do directly because now
they are all scalars
we take this argument here and copy it
here
we next take this one and add it here
and finally we take this argument and
add it
at the end where i'm already expanding
out the square
rewriting this the x squared term here
gives this this term
and this term are proportional to x and
combine to this
and this term and this term are
proportional to lambda squared
combining to give this using this result
we can combine the exponentials and
rewrite
the h function as the pre-factor
and then this single exponential
we're almost there let's make a change
of variables to z
equal to square root of m omega
over h bar times x and t
equals lambda over square root of 2.
using these new variables we can rewrite
the original h function up here
as h of z and t equal to the pre-factor
and then the exponential in terms of the
new variables
remembering from earlier in the video
that the generating function of the
hermit polynomials has
this form we can now see that these two
terms of the exponential here
are precisely the generating function g
this means that we can rewrite
the function h as equal to the
pre-factor
then the exponential of minus z squared
over two
and then the generating function g of
the hermit polynomials
and that's it we set out to find an
equation between the h and g
functions and we found it
before we take the final step we can
also rewrite this final equation
using the x lambda variables rather than
the zt variables like this
this is the key equation to relate the
eigen states of the quantum harmonic
oscillator with the hermit polynomials
on the one hand the function h can be
written as a serious expansion in terms
of the eigenstates of the quantum
harmonic oscillator
on the other hand the function g can be
written as a series expansion in terms
of the hermit polynomials
so using the relations up here between z
and x and between t
and lambda we can rewrite the expansion
of g
in terms of x and lambda
and now finally the very last step
the function h is related to the
function g by this equation up here
we're now going to rewrite this equation
using the power series representations
of the functions h and g
starting with h here we get this for the
left-hand side of the equation
for the right hand side we first copy
the prefactors here
which give this
and now we need the g function for which
we use this expansion
and end up with this
you can see i have conveniently isolated
the power of lambda here
and here to obey this equation the
coefficients of each power
must be equal to each other moving this
term dividing the other side
then we can write the nth eigenstate of
the quantum harmonic oscillator
as equal to these three factors
and then a gaussian function and finally
a hermit polynomial of order n
and we are done these are the energy
eigenfunctions of the quantum harmonic
oscillator
in terms of the hermit polynomials
if you've made it all the way to this
point it's great news because it means
that you probably really like maths
and that's fantastic if you want to be
proficient in quantum mechanics you will
most often see the wave functions of the
energy eigenstates of the quantum
harmonic oscillator written in terms
of permit polynomials so i hope that
you've enjoyed
finding out more about where these
polynomials come from so as always
if you liked the video please subscribe